hello everyone my name is saurav and i'm
part of the simply learn team
welcome to this session on ethereum so
now let's take a look
what's in it for all of us today we will
be talking about what is ethereum
the features of ethereum like
cryptocurrency smart contracts ethereum
virtual machine
decentralized application and it uses
and decentralized autonomous
organization
we'll be also looking at applications of
ethereum and
a demo on smart contract deployment on a
locally running ethereum client now what
is ethereum
ethereum is a blockchain based computing
platform
that enables developers to build
and deploy decentralized applications so
basically
ethereum is a platform where we can
build applications
which are not run by a centralized
authority
you can create a decentralized
application where the participants
of that particular application are the
decision making authority so
here we can see ethereum allows us to
build and deploy
dap applications now what are the
typical features of
ethereum ethereum allows you to use
its own cryptocurrency called it allows
development and deployment of smart
contracts it provides you
the underlying technology the
architecture the software
which understands smart contracts and
allow you to interact with it which is
called ethereum virtual machine then it
allows eventually to create
consolidated applications called
decentralized applications
and also it allows you to create
decentralized autonomous organizations
now let's talk about
ethereum cryptocurrency ether eth is a
cryptocurrency
that runs on ethereum network basically
it is the fuel
which is running the ethereum network it
is used to pay for the computational
resources
and the transaction fees for any
transaction
to be executed on an ethereum network
like bitcoin
ether is also a peer-to-peer currency
apart from
paying for transaction ether is also
used to buy gas
which is used to pay for computation of
any transaction you make on an ethereum
network also if you have to deploy
a contract on ethereum network you will
need gas and you would have to pay
for that gas in ethers so gas is the
execution fee
paid by a user for running a transaction
in ethereum ether can be utilized for
building decentralized applications for
building your smart contracts
and making standard peer-to-peer
payments now
what is a smart contract a smart
contract is a simple
computer program that facilitates the
exchange
of any valuable asset between two
parties
it could be money it could be shares it
could be property
or it could be any other digital asset
which you want to exchange
these contracts can be created by anyone
on the ethereum network and primarily
the contract
consists of the terms and conditions
mutually agreed
between the parties between the peers
and the primary feature of a smart
contract is that once it is executed it
cannot be altered
and any transaction done on top of a
smart contract
is registered permanently it is
immutable so even
in future you modify the smart contract
the transactions correlated with the
original contract
does not get altered or you cannot
modify them so for the verification
process smart contract
is carried out amongst the anonymous
parties of the network
without the need of a centralized
authority and that's what
makes any smart contract execution
on ethereum a decentralized execution
it provides the transfer of any asset or
currency in a transparent and a
trustworthy manner
as the two entities are totally unaware
their identity is secure on the ethereum
network
though the transactions once
successfully done the accounts of the
sender and receiver are updated
accordingly and therefore it generates a
trust between the
parties who are transacting using the
ethereum network now what happens in
traditional system of contract in
traditional systems of contract
you sign an agreement then you trust a
third party hire a third party for
execution now
the problem is that in such an
engagement the data tampering is
possible
now if we talk about the new smart
contract the agreement
is coded in a program now result is not
verified by a centralized authority it
is verified by the participants on
ethereum
based blockchain network now once a
contract is executed
the transaction is registered and it
cannot be altered or tampered so it
removes the risk of any data
manipulation or
alteration now let's take another
example where zack has given a contract
of 500 to elsa for developing his
company's website now the developers
code the agreement of smart contract
using ethereum's programming language
now the smart contract has all the
conditions the requirements
for building the website once the code
is written it is uploaded
and deployed on the ethereum evm virtual
machine
evm is a runtime compiler to execute
your smart contract
once the code is deployed on the evm
every participant on the network has a
copy of the contract now
now when elsa submits the work on
ethereum for evaluation
each node on the ethereum network will
evaluate
and confirm whether the result given by
elsa is done
as per the coding requirements and once
approved and
verified the contract worth 500 dollars
will be self-executed
and the payment will be paid to elsa in
ethers
so john's account the person who had
gone into a contract his account will be
automatically debited and elsa will be
credited with
500 in ether denomination here we will
now
take a look we will do a demo small demo
on a
deployment of a smart contract so for in
order to
execute our smart contract we will need
two set of softwares
ganache and truffle and we will show you
in the demo how to install
these two softwares on your machine now
we will be giving a demo
on the following smart contract this is
a smart contract
where we are writing a simple contract
of a greeter
we have a variable called greeting which
we will
be initializing using a constructor and
then
in our demo we will be showing how you
can change the value of
the variable greeting using the set
grating method and read the value using
the greet method
this is the other contract where we will
be
defining that whoever is deploying the
contract on the blockchain network
is always the owner of the contract and
then we have defined
certain mandatory functions in order to
kill the contract on the ethereum
network so only the
owner of the contract can kill it now
let's talk about
what is an ethereum virtual machine itse
virtual machine
is designed to operate as a runtime
environment
for compiling and deploying ethereum
based
smart contracts basically evm is the
engine which understands
the language of smart contracts which
are written in solidity language for
ethereum
evm is operated in a sandbox environment
basically you can deploy your own
standalone environment which can
act as a testing and a development
environment and you can
n number of times test your smart
contract deploy it
verify it and then once you are
satisfied with the performance
and the functionality of the smart
contract you can deploy it on the
ethereum main net now any programming
language in the smart contract
is compiled into the byte code which
the evm understands this byte code can
be read
and executed you using an ethereum
feature called ethereum virtual machine
so basically
avm machine understands a byte code so
one of the most popular languages
for writing a smart contract is solidity
so once you write your smart
contract on solidity that contract gets
converted into the byte code and gets
deployed on the eb
and thereby evm guarantees security from
cyber attack now how does evm work
so suppose a wants to pay b
10 ethers the transaction will be sent
to the evm using a
smart contract for a funds transfer from
a to b
now in order to validate the transaction
the ethereum network
will perform the proof of work consensus
algorithm
the minor nodes on the ethereum will
validate this transaction
whether the first the identity of a
exist or not a
has the relevant amount of balance to
transfer 10 ether
to b and in will validate the
transaction once validated
the ether will be debited from a's
wallet and will be credited to
b's wallet and during this course the
miners
will charge a fees in order to validate
this transaction
and will earn a reward now all the nodes
on ethereum network
execute smart contract using their
respective
evms now how does proof of work works
every node in the ethereum network has
the
entire history of all the transactions
the entire chain
it has the history of smart contract
this
basically the address at which the smart
contract is deployed the transactions
associated with the smart contract and
also it has the handle to the current
state of the smart contract now
the goal of the miners on the ethereum
blockchain
network is to validate the block for
each block of transaction
miners use the computational power and
resources
to get the appropriate hash value by
varying the nonce
now the miners will vary the nonce and
pass it through a hashing algorithm
in case of ethereum it is the it hash
algorithm this produces a hash value
which should be lesser than the
predefined target
as per the proof of work consensus if
the hash value generated
is less than the target value then only
the block
is considered to be verified and the
miner gets rewarded only then
now when the proof of work is solved
result is broadcasted and shared with
all the other nodes
in order to update their ledger if other
nodes accept the hash block as valid
then the block gets added to the
ethereum mainnet blockchain and
as a result the miner receives a reward
which as of today
stands at three ethers plus the miner
receives the
transaction fees which has been
generated for verifying the block all
the transactions which are aggregated in
the block the cumulative transaction
fees associated with all the
transactions
is also rewarded to the miner now let's
understand the concept of
gas now ethereum virtual machine has a
concept of gas and why do we need it so
like we need fuel to run
car in the same way in order to run
application on ethereum network
we need gas now what is gas to perform
any transactional ethereum network a
user has to make a payment
has to shell out ethers in order to get
the execution done
the transaction done and the
intermediary monetary value is called as
gas
on ethereum network gas is a unit that
measures the computational power
required to run a smart contract or a
transaction so if you have to do a
transaction which is
updating the blockchain you would have
to shell out gas
and that gas will come with a price in
ethers
now how is the gas fees calculated
in ethereum the transaction fees is
calculated in ethereum
using the below formula for every
transaction there is a gas
and the correlated gas price so the
amount of gas required to execute a
transaction
multiplied by the gas price you generate
the transaction fees so gas
limit on ethereum network refers to the
amount of gas
which is used for the computation and
the amount of ether a user is required
to pay
for the gas now here we have a
screenshot from the ethereum
mainnet where the cost of transaction is
being shown
so if you see for this particular
example transaction
the gas limit was 21 000 the gas used by
the transaction was 21
000 and the gas price was 21 gui which
is the lowest denomination so 21 degree
into 21 000
gave you the actual transaction fees
which is 0.00441 ether which is
approximately
0.21 cents as of today's ether market
value
now this transaction fee goes to the
miner
who has validated the transaction to
understand the gas limit
and the gas price in a better way let's
consider an example of a car
suppose your car has a mileage of 10
kilometers
and the price of patrol is one dollar
per liter
then driving a car for 50 kilometers
will cost you 5 liters of patrol which
will be worth 5 dollars similarly
to perform an operation or to run a code
on ethereum
you need to obtain certain amount of gas
like the patrol
where each gas has a per unit price
called
gas price now if the user provides less
amount of gas to run a particular
operation
then the process will fail and the user
will be given a message of
out of gas and gui is the lowest
denomination
of ether which is used for measuring
unit of a gas
price now how is ethereum's mining
different from
bitcoin mining the hashing algorithm is
the primary difference
the bitcoin uses sha-256 ethereum uses
it
the average time taken on bitcoin for
mining a block is 10 minutes whereas in
ethereum it is 12 to 15 seconds
as of today the mining reward for
bitcoin is 12.5 btc
but for ethereum it is three ethers plus
the transaction fee the accumulated
transaction
fee for all the transactions for a block
now as of 23rd july
the bitcoin value was 7667 dollars
whereas
one ether stands at 466 dollars
now here we have a screenshot of
ethereum reward which has been
given to the miner of the block now as
you can see here is the breakup of the
reward three ethers
plus the total accumulated transaction
fee
of all the underlying transactions in
this block
which is 0.0666 ethos
now what is a decentralized application
now let's compare it
with our traditional applications our
traditional websites which are currently
running so for example when you log into
twitter a web application
gets displayed which is rendered using
an html page now the page
will call an api to access your personal
data
your information which is centrally
hosted now it's a simple process your
front end
executes a back-end api and the api goes
and fetches the information from a
centralized db now if we transform this
application into a decentralized
application
then now when you will log in the same
web application will get rendered
but it will be calling a smart
contract-based api
to fetch the information from the
blockchain network so the api gets
replaced with the smart contract
interface and the smart contract will
fetch the information from the
blockchain network which is its backend
and that blockchain network is not a
centralized db
it's a decentralized network where the
participants of the network
the miners of the network are validating
verifying all the transactions which are
happening
using the smart contract on the
blockchain network so thereby
any now any transaction or any action
happening on the twitter kind of
application which has been transformed
will now cannot be claimed as a
centralized uh transaction it will be
a decentralized transaction a dapp a
decentralized application
consists of backend code that runs on a
distributed
peer-to-peer network it is a software
designed to work
on an ethereum network without being
controlled by a
centralized system and that is the
primary difference
it provides the direct interaction
between the
end users and the decentralized
application providers
now an application qualifies as dap when
it is open sourced
its code is there on github and it uses
a public blockchain based token in order
to run the application
a token acts as a fuel for the
decentralized application to run
dap allows the backend code and data to
be decentralized and that is the primary
architecture of any dap now let's
discuss what are decentralized
autonomous organizations
daos is a digital organizations that
wants to operate without any need of a
hierarchical management
it wants to operate in a decentralized
and democratized fashion
so basically a dao is an organization
where
the decision making should not be in the
hands of a centralized authority
but it should be in the hands of certain
designated
authorities or a group of designated
people as a part of authority
it exists on a blockchain network where
it is governed by the protocols
embedded in a smart contract and thereby
they rely
on a smart contract for decision making
all the business decisions
are driven by the smart contracts or we
can say
a decentralized voting system within the
organization so any
organizational decision before being
taken has to go through the voting
system which is running on a
decentralized
application so how it work people add
funds to the dow because
dao requires funding in order to execute
and take decisions
based on that each member is given a
token
on a percentage basis which represents
the percentage of shares
of that particular member in the dow now
those tokens
are used to vote in the dao where the
proposal status is decided
based on the maximum votes so every
decision
within the organization has to go
through this voting process
now let's take a look what are the
applications of ethereum
in real world and where it is getting
used so as we have seen with dao
voting systems are adopting it the
results of the polls are publicly
available
where it ensures a transparent and fair
democracy by eliminating
voting malpractices it is getting
adopted widely in a banking scenarios
and banking systems
with ethereum's decentralized system it
is becoming very difficult for hackers
to have
unauthorized access and it also allows
payments on an ethereum based network so
banks are also using
ethereum as a channel to make
remittances and payments
shipping deploying ethereum and shipping
helps tracking
of cargo and prevents goods from being
misplaced or counterfeited
so basically ethereum is providing you
of the provenance and
tracking framework for any kind of asset
required in a typical supply chain now
with ethereum's
smart contract agreements can be
maintained and executed without
any alteration so any industry which has
fragmented participants
is subject to disputes and which
requires
and digital contracts to be present then
ethereum
can definitely be used as a technology
for
developing your smart contract and
digitally recording the agreements and
the transactions based on those
agreements
so let's get started for a demo on how
to deploy
an ethereum smart contract locally so
in order to deploy a smart contract we
will be first
installing ganache client which allows
you to host
a local ethereum client on which you can
deploy
your smart contract so as we are working
on the windows environment
when we are downloading the ganache
setup we can
also download node order to
install truffle on our machines
now as the node has been downloaded we
will
install node
so now node is successfully installed
now we are going to install ganache
locally
now we will run ganache a little later
before that
we will perform certain steps or
we can run ganache and see so once
ganache is up and running
i'll show you the interface how it looks
so when ganache is brought up it
automatically creates
10 accounts with pre-funded balance of
100 ethers it is running on localhost
port number 7545 now as you see
there is no transaction or anything
which has currently happened
so the current block is 0 which is the
genesis block
there are no transactions and there are
no blocks
as of now so there are no
transactions in block which have been
generated so
using this ganache client now we will be
deploying our
greeter contract now as we have
installed node
we will be installing truffle
ruffle is the utility which allows us to
compile and deploy
ethereum contracts okay now
once a truffle is installed
we need to create a directory called
greater
now we need to run the command truffle
now once we run this command ruffle by
default
creates a package structure which has
three folders called contracts
migrations test truffle.js and truffle
config
now we will be writing our smart
contract called
greeter.soul and we will compile
and deploy basically our greater.soul
will be under contracts folder and we
can
our contract is created and it is lying
under contracts folder
now we need to add another file under
migrations folder called as deploy
contract.js
so we will name it as deploy contract
now in this deploy contract you need to
put
line of code
now in this file we are asking
truffle to deploy our newly created
greeter.soul file now in the greater
contract
we have a constructor we are
initializing
the greater contract with a value high
hello
and we are passing a gas value so this
gas is currently
at a higher limits and we know that this
gas value
the contract will get executed but
otherwise you can also
evaluate the gas value of a contract
using remix
now once this file is being saved you go
to the
truffle.js and make the
following entry
now here we are telling truffle that our
localhost ganache client is running on
localhost at port number 7545
and network id can be anything though
the current ganache client is running on
port network id five triple seven
but we have kept it open that we can
connect to any network id
now after this step i need to go back to
my
command prompt and say refer
compile now if you get this error
if we are getting this kind of error in
windows
then need to do one quick fix
we need to go to the users directory and
rename truffle.cmd to trough
so i'll go to my drive users
him just
oh here now instead of truffle i have to
say trough
now there might be certain compilation
warnings we can ignore
that now my contract has been compiled
now i need to run the next command
trough migrate
at this stage my smart contract is
deployed
and now you can see
this is the step this is the place where
the contract has been called
and this is the transaction where the
default value of my variable greater has
been set to high hello
so we will see now i need to run command
trough console to interact with my
contract
now as on my truff console i can
check at what address is my
contract deployed so my contract is
deployed at
address 0x37 which matches with the
address
0x373
now i need to check the default value
which i had set
while deploying my contract so this is
my value
high hello now i can change the value
to something else because in my greater
contract
i have a method called set greeting now
whenever when i'll be
performing this action a new block
will get generated and the block count
will increase from 4 to 5
because i am making a change on the
blockchain as you can see now
a new transaction has been created this
was the gas
used this is the default gas price in
ganache
and block number five has been mined now
i can
re-read the value of the variable now it
will return me
latest value which is change greet value
so this
demonstrates how to use
a solidity contract how to compile it
deploy it
on a locally running blockchain network
you can
connect multiple nodes to this ganache
client
and all the nodes should be running on
the same network id should have the same
network id
but they can be running on a different
machine so here we can
see all the other details the block the
transactions which have happened
if i perform the action again
number six has been generated has
another transaction associated with it
and i can get the latest value so what
are the key takeaways for today we
understood about ethereum
the features of ethereum different
applications of ethereum
and what is a smart contract i hope you
had a great learning session
and i'll meet you in the next session
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here